yeah briefly talked about there are a
lot of interesting directions that I
didn't get a chance to talk about so
there is that there are applications of
all of these to approximation algorithms
that's something I've worked on so so
very briefly so forth for symmetric TSP
you have this paper of with moist thing
and having summary where where we so
here is what we do we actually using use
linear programming find you find a
vector X such that it lives in like it
assigns a non-negative number to every
edge of the graph such that it has two
properties summation of X e4e neighbor
of V is equal to two so each vertex has
a fractional degree to X is not integral
it's fractional each vertex as
fractional degree two and summation of
Yi and ricotta as as complement is at
least two so if X was an integral vector
this would characterize the Hamiltonian
cycle but it's not integral is
fractional so we have so called a
fractional Hamiltonian cycle well now
here's the interesting thing if you look
at the vector X times 1 minus 1 over N
and is the number of vertices of the
graph this vector is in the spanning
tree pollito so so what you get is that
there exists this lambda such that
lambda star mu has marginal equal to X
so probability of the edge e in lambda
star mu is basically equal to x times 1
minus 1 over n just essentially X so so
for example what do you get out of this
you get that if you look at the expected
degree of vertex V if I look at the
expected degree of a vertex V in a
random spanning tree sample from lambda
star mu this is equal to 2 times 1 minus
1 over
so so now you can use all these nice
properties of a strong riling
distributions to say that not only in
aesthetics unexpected degree - because
the distribution is unimodal or concave
and so on and so forth with a constant
probability the degree of this vertex
will be too so so from this you get that
the probability that the degree of V is
equal to two is at least one over each
vertex this is true yes I mean when two
fires go so it so for every week v the
probability is at least one over you
right yes the probability for every for
every V the probability that this is
equal to two is at least 1 over e yeah
it's no miracle yeah
so in fact constant fraction of vertices
will have degree 2 like 1 over a
fraction of vertices in expectation will
have degree 2 there are more interesting
stuff we can prove so if you use more
negative correlation property we can
prove something like this that if you
have two vertices U and V where they are
not neighbors then the probability that
the degree of U is equal to two and
degree of V is also equal to two is at
least constant
okay so this this is I mean this is sort
of trivial like from all I said so far
this money is a lot of calculation so we
use a lot of other properties of a
strong value distribution that I haven't
discussed like negative association is
to cast the covering property so you can
prove this satisfy the second one as
well oh I can get a quarter for a second
[Music]
even even if they have an edge so if
they have an edge the proof goes true as
long as the probability of the edge is
not one hat like bounded away from one
half you can take it and but there are
lots of things we don't know like what
if this is the set of two is three but
can you prove something or more like if
you a bunch of vertices which do not
have any edges with each other can you
prove that all of them will have degree
2 so that constant probability so so the
thing is like okay the upshot is that
you expect to have a lot of independence
when you sample from these strong value
distributions but usually it gets hard
to prove and so it's okay so I didn't
say use these two properties so these
are approximation algorithms for TSP
it's imaginable if you have a stronger
statements you may improve the
approximation only fact so in fact what
we studied a graphical version of TSP
which is sort of the Unrated version so
it's imaginable if you prove if you know
these things better you can get bounds
for the for the weighted version of TSP
so that's like one open-ended direction
to prove more properties of the
distribution properties
explicitly like I think one explicit one
is that if you have UV and W with no age
to that probability that they all have
degree 2 is a constant and you expect
this recruit for any car so I expect
this to be I expect the constant to an
exponentially go down my expect this to
be true for know that that part is not
yeah that's like it's a toy problem in
understanding these things better yes
the fact that is the spanning tree I
mean it's a point of the spanning tree
pollito pieces because it's convenient
or is there something could you think
any other positive and oh you mean so
this proof actually doesn't use the fact
that this is spanning tree pollito to a
point in the spanning tree is just a
coincidence or is it something it is
sort of a coincidence it's because I
mean in a sense it's because the
Hamiltonian cycle is really a spanning
three plus and H so when you when you
scale it down by BA - not over an
ascension in your for any other problem
we'll get another positive yeah so so
that's that's one line of works related
to optimization there is a different
line of work related to later - Counting
so counting so I didn't talk about it
but there exists that exists the Markov
chain it's a simple Markov chain
basically they're just metropolis rule
that if you have a given an Oracle or
for coefficient of each monomial let's
say coefficient of every monomial say Z
to the S we can generate s from a mover
bean with strong right and the Markov
chain is very simple basically given s
you randomly delete an element of s and
randomly add a new element
ok so sorry this Markov chain is for the
homogeneous ones
okay so you randomly remove an element
randomly add a new element and you take
the transition with probability the
ratio of the two probabilities okay so
well defined Markov chain you can easily
run it and so we proved in a work with
NEMA show that we show that the spectral
gap of this chain is at most 1 over K
star DN T so so using this you can
generate that samples from the DP
blockade from like VD bps you can
generate random spanning trees run
disparities we already knew but you can
generate from any other strong rally
distributions in particular you can
compute ok I delete it but you can we
can also
a compute G mu at any z1 after the end
there they are non-negative I can also
do that yes
so is it like a discrete version of
strong mixing for ha genetic flaws or
hyperbolic 24 so like the strong rail it
looks like it's the discrete version of
negatively curved well it's actually
it's actually possible because you chain
comes from the issue of its ratio of
like s vs s minus I plus J I don't see
how you related to this year because I
saw some change which was essentially
there's a there's another paper for for
law concave distribution that's related
to Hessian this is the this before that
s it also applies yes so again if I'm
not if I'm not mistaken so you started
for a normal day this is like doubly
stochastic derivative at 1
this one derivative of marginals in each
where goes the evil good job it doesn't
have to be actually in order here Tony
scale you have to be able to compute so
that's yeah you don't need to risk it so
okay so that's so okay so now what's
open problem so so this so this result
basically says that for for these DPP's
we can compute so if mu is a DP to say
KD p p you can compute summation of the
same us for example or marginal
probability or I mean summation of us
where I is less we can compute these
kind of quantities now there are these
interesting questions of computing this
for the same thing for mu to the P where
P is some number different from 1 and so
so for machine learning application
there is an open problem like if you
read the survey on V bps there is open
problem for P equals 2
that's a very interesting of a problem
so I should say we have a follow-up
paper we can we can now compute this for
every strand Rayleigh distribution as
long as P is less than 1 or less than or
equal to 1 but for P greater than 1 we
know nothing and there's a lot of
interest because lucky like for P equals
2 this would kind of correspond to like
I get a second moment of your of your
distribution or there's a different
thing different quantity which is also
of interest something like if you have
mu and mu prime so generalization of
this you want to estimate summation of
mu s times mu prime of x over all set
that is sum of coefficients to the
borrower this is the sum of each
coefficient based on the power P
factorial here I'm talking about the
mutiny mutia fine cakes for the
factorial saying you don't really need
factorials here because it's mostly a
fine there's no factorial so let's come
from venue may not mean it's not moved
here for even in that case we know
nothing just it's just a multi a fine
case there's no yeah we know nothing
okay we know okay sorry I should be
careful we know for both of these we
know a deterministic algorithm which
gives either than approximation that's
paper of me and nima but the interesting
thing is to get 1 plus epsilon
approximation for either of the two this
is easier but okay we don't know that
this is also related in one way or other
to mix characteristic polynomial so the
coefficient of the polynomial get from
carousel singer are related to this
object in P yeah but you cannot get one
plus epsilon for these things we can get
e to the end since that's not an issue
they issues to get 1 plus epsilon
approximation maybe I don't know you can
continue but maybe if anybody has a
question
be homogeneous so you can be example
right genius then it's hard to say oh
sorry yeah so - this good good so here I
assume it's the homogeneous if it is not
the homogeneous there's a follow up
paper by Lee Jagielka and straw we show
that there's a different chain we show
that it actually mixes the mixing time
is a little bit slower but it works and
basically that the rough idea is that
you can actually homogenized that's the
best thing is if she is not homogeneous
you can homogenized and then generate
sample from there yeah so there are some
other interesting questions just ok
let's say 1 minute so there is this
question of extending strong rally
distributions to like infinitely many
variables or generate samples from that
so that's a very open-ended question
like what can be said or what what do we
know about these things there are the
reason it's interesting is that there
are VP PS for continuous domain and they
are of interest so I have a paper on
them but for for a strong Riley we don't
know much so that's something I'm open
ended question you can think about
there's also this connection to some
other distribution you can get from
piped rounding or swap rounding don't
have time to tell you about it but you
can ask me later so the question of how
those distributions are related to
solution
okay let's say on the what if there's no
yoga no it's actually easy to easy to
those mattresses and they okay no you
can generate as a sum of independent
you're saying talk about basically
asking this determinant of summation of
zi i wear a eyes are PST you're assuming
you can you don't have aberration yeah
so there's a special case of this where
this is Rank 2 and then it's closely
related to this thing I was saying there
you have a evaluation Oracle but then
you don't know how that we don't know
how to do it yeah I'm not saying it's
easy I'm saying I think there we have a
valuation Oracle if you if you tell me
yeah sir you right for onto it it says
mix this cream and you're right
yeah I agree this is actually because
for instance the major program in
quantum linear optics is to this vendor
strength of the drama
we would like to generate so this is the
opposite question so so so far I was
asking that you know the coefficient you
want to compute the polynomial
generating polynomial or the generating
function so do not a sample for rank two
they give you related to that question
corresponds to yeah mixed discriminant
of rank two but but for many of these
things there's a natural Markov chain
especially here for exam for P less than
or equal to two it seems that the
National Markov chain should mix it's
just we're lacking techniques to to
prove it